lorenzo dimmi tutto ci cattivo è una
cittadina di città corso commercio anche
a torino ce l'abbiamo
infatti questo e torino infatti torino
lavori conoscere ti dico ci stanno 1234
barra 5 tema
davanti a noi c'è cazzola dentro sta
salendo non armati lo giuro perfetto
appena meno male vecchia di fare male al
mio amico poi tra l'altro lauren shuler
a1 arrivo ha preso l'arma dato arriva
non ne ho idea eccolo vedo lo riesco
perché un secondo
aspetta un secondo così non è se vieni
qua
loro mi devi dire qualcosa hai per caso
sparato sotto di noi ma arriva perdendo
qualche non fatti nei quarti nel quadro
qua eccolo buongiorno porca vacca molta
gente e dolore ecco a sinistra qua sotto
sì che sia qua sotto
vabbè senti come mai tu entri nelle
porte senza bussare riposo ma non sta
mai non lo vedo sempre arrivano arrivano
eccolo ok malissimo ma basta quanta
gente ride e allora il cecchino tra
l'altro grazie ciccioli senso ma da che
parte stanno entrando vanno sotto come
il rum e le ci apra c'è male madonna che
brutta cosa vedo
eni potremmo andarcene via scarpa porca
vacca che male ho visto la morte in
faccia per judy quando mandato quel 2 in
chimica e stato orribile c madonna è
brutta roba ma dov'è eccolo allora le
ninja e tom cruise
ok bravo però ha fatto un salto da james
bond occhio ma vogliono che lui ci ha
attirato le granate io costruiti muri e
per quello che possiamo essere quello
che non si va avanti
c'è la vera se la granata la tirava
mezzo centimetro più ad essere morti
comune a molti pare infatti ci ha
aiutato anche un po il signore in quella
zona beh se io vedo
vabbè ma il signore un bravo signore lo
aspetta un commesso non si aspetta
ebbene ecco lì sono qua sono qua dove a
destra destra mia cielo davanti e mi
hanno visto ma niente ma niente
no non ha mancato una battuta con ha
beccato e mori quanto tempo ma non ci
credo politico e non aveva niente te lo
giuro non riuscivo più a colpirlo perché
avrei voluto due di vita ci credo che
domani col fucile da caccia capito mi
hai fatto bene fatto bene anche a noi
nun tene zio 255 mi hanno fatto un male
zio che tu davvero o no quasi ecc
bella la bomba ha battuto 1 0 abbiamo
bruciato forza velocità subito
gravissimo quante bombe shiu mai rock ma
è bravo bravo così si monetizza
maledizione oddio è il monito quello che
ci piace è bello sono saltati in aria
fortino rete vittoria vittoria è di
storia reale incognite vittoria del 1100
euro sulla vittoria punto è ma vieni
vieni vieni con me non gli regalo a
surreal power
entra qua dentro vai ok sparato un secco
non ne ho la piu pallida out e non lo so
che arrivano certi schiaffi che ok o
prendi lo prendi ma tu lo sapevi sta
cosa è se io non avevo pica capitolo di
fare questo paese allo zio l'ho visto a
75 va bene estate che idiota non ha mica
capito vorresti passarola camp nou dove
sei non ha nome morino memori aspetta in
questa eccomi signore degli anelli per
fa qua qua pasqua e devo uscire vai vai
vai coi muri riesci a come va va bene no
due muri 2 munizzi due muri bravo 11 ma
pechino mai a mare una rottura cavani
paribas am e sa che qua no no scusa
ciccia scusaci scusa scusa ho fatto una
cosa bruttissima me lo merito vedove no
non volevo farlo scusa un video te lo
giuro non fa ma dai due esseri animato
styla stai mai ma successo io maghetti
conosce o che fa capo a noi tutti di
mano e se sì vabbè però è stato è stato
carica no no è stata piegata porco
quindi sempre su questi edifici neri
così tutti assai un pochino va bene non
sei tu questo ma cazzo sono un
deficiente
occorre non ho seguito un altro che però
in compenso un fucile d'assalto viola
quindi sei oscar
c'è un buco di culo bruciate scar pieni
come vieni con me senso forziere
scusate se uno scudo viola laiche succo
succoso è prenderlo premi la fantasia
che ci hanno vestito lorenzo c6 medica
andiamo namo le seguo che era nata di
impulsi questa sparata è quella della
riguarda vieni qui vieni qui vieni qua
adesso praticamente del prendi la gara
in full si e metti della sotto i piedi è
messo pure fatto male è fantastico e
meraviglioso chiarissime mi piace un
sacco per ascoltare bene ci fa un sacco
di cose con quella cioè procure
ammazzare amici dai nemici fa danno e
best bilanci come hai fatto dessì quindi
se loro stanno sopra sopra tulli lanci
quella sottoli che poi li butti giù
capito davanti e di 330 sparano fatto tu
sei un culo che parla a si è ma dopo
questa si fa schifo lo puoi di fare
eccolo lì che corre anche o mio dio mi
sa che l'hai ucciso ma non accetto
questo schifo di fucile l'ho massacrato
con elevato 220 madonna lo rotto lo è
e mi sa che di vista dato gioco anomalo
perché bravo cc a me piace per la bella
non rotto cazzo però non ho capito chi
cacchio stava spara a lui perché mi
sembrava ha davanti a noi ma veramente
dov'erano 165 m vieni qua aia che mara
destro destra io sto volando vieni vieni
vieni vieni giù che mai vengo
eccoci ok ho già visto l'altro porca
[ __ ] vorrei questo mi fa memoria che
dolore si chiamava jesse un politico o
l'ho colpito talmente tante volte si è
cagato sotto te lo giuro
certo ma neanche un colpo è entrato
maledizione
ora il club fra inter e intra entra in
trenta c'era uno qua dentro
calamai c'entra ha dichiarato centrato
davanti a noi
io
abbattuto uno fra qua
ok bravo perfetto allora però madonna
sono un po troppi pure per me è successo
un inizio col fucile da caccia 288
diranno che ho fatto in testa la imploso
vieni vieni lorello lorno aperto a metà
questo questo si aperto vieni qui vieni
qua e ce ne andiamo dritti dove vado io
via vai
si vola madonna etica testa eccola
occhio
aspetto aia porca vacca indietro porca
vacca lei che uccide
bravo c così non poteva morire da uno
che si chiamava dottor placebo
maledizione o cazzo lo re no non è il
migliore non me lo dire
vai vai via arriva equa e come
fondamento è bravissimo madonna che
giocatore con niente di vita ma lo vedo
lo vedo lo mettono per ora scala maki
maki porca eva
ecco badoer ci credo vai vai vai rai ma
con un niente di vita qualora come sto
cacasotto con niente diritta o mio dio
vai vai vai vai vai piano bar carispaq
già 13 kill
anch'io non ho forse anche un 3
bravo se va bene che ha soffiato al sud
ce l'hai
malizia ma da te la stai giocando bene
la riduzione mancavano 5 divide ragazzi
bravo fatti
devo fare praticamente sì vabbè o ma sti
cazzi e ben giocato bene cioè hai
giocato io ho fatto la mia bellissima
killer che vale ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto ringrazio ciccio per avermi
dato una mano c'è in realtà li dove
insegnare un po giocate anomale noi
abbiamo una prossima volta ti spiego
meglio come giocare perché però per
adesso se la cava molto bene secondo ok
grazie mille non è tra greco ciccio
prego casa inter si evince come ti piace
crescere quindi denti senza amore siate
non ci vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]